aujourd'hui face à trump écouter on
n'existe pas vous le savez bien
donc j'espère que si françois fillon est
élu il aura plus de charisme et de
volonté face à tremper à poutine mais
pas emmanuel macron un gamin qui ne
connaît rien aux gamins qui me connaît
rien s'est il est candidat à l'élection
présidentielle oui les capacités il ya
jean yves le drian d'ailleurs lu par
exemple ah oui je croyais qu'ils
prenaient pas de d'ancien président
consomme 90 et qu'il a besoin de ces
cautions notamment sur ces questions
ce qu'il a dit hier il ne connaît
strictement rien à rien s'il devient
président oui ça m'inquiète parce que là
il est il a commencé par dire on va
faire une opération militaire
oui mais après à la fin et dit non c'est
pas une opération militaire
on n'envoie pas de troupes et une
opération militaire sans voix elle
trouve ni d'avions jeu pas comment ça
peut se passer il dit on va aller punir
bastad
et puis après on le prend pour une
négociation c'était absolument
incompréhension